I remember wishing my mom would stop fucking cleaning
and just sit and watch a movie with me.
Or, like,
how much I didn't care what we had for dinner.
But I would have loved to, um,
tell her a story with her undivided attention.
And, you know,
I've grown up to understand that she was giving me love
in the way that she thought that was best delivered.
But that's exactly why I left my miserable marriage.
I decided I was not gonna stay for the kids.
Because I wanted my kids to know me.
I didn't want.
I didn't want them to have to wait until they were adults
to start to get to know me.
To be able to ask me questions and get to know my actual opinions. And.
Oh, mom,
I always thought you liked it this way.
No, we just always did it that way.
Cause the way we. We did it,
that's the way your father liked it.
I didn't want that. I wanted them to know me.
I also felt like.
I think a lot of times women are in a shitty relationship
and then they decide,
maybe if we just move on to the next phase of the relationship,
things will get better. And that next phase is usually marriage or, like,
having a kid. And you kind of just think like, no, no, no.
All the problems will go away when we just, like,
get to the goal. The point
Of all this once we have the kids,
once we get the house, once we do, like,
whatever ABC.
And then you reach that point
and then the relationship still isn't better,
and you're just getting more and more miserable and lonely.
But you just, like,
keep holding on cause you're like, no,
it'll. It'll get better.
And you don't realize that you're like,
all that happened was
you were in a shitty relationship that you should have broken up with.
Like, you guys should never have stayed together,
but you kept pushing forward.
And now you've brought children into that shitty relationship,
and you are kind of ignoring your children
to focus on that shitty relationship.
And now you're using the kids as an excuse
to make that relationship the focus of your life,
when in reality, you just need to,
if you wanna be a, like,
have a good relationship with your kids,
drop the shitty relationship that has always been a source of, um,
pain in your life. A consistent source of pain.
Even if it brings you pleasure from time to time,
it's been a consistent source of pain.
So you need to let go of that relationship
so that you can focus on your kids.
Cause I think it's really shitty to bring people into this world
and then be like, sorry,
I got other things I'm focusing on right now.
I got this guy I've been trying to chase for 15,
20, Years
and get him to, like,
like me. So you guys are gonna have to fucking wait with, like,
your needs and shit and your, like, development. Okay?
You know, that just seems kind of shitty.
So I'm sorry that you didn't get a happy mom.
And I'm trying my best to be a happy mom, to, like,
pay it forward in the world,
to honor women like you. So
I love you.